bonjour à vous matteo il averti merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors ça y est les présidentielles la
présidentielle italienne s'achève enfin
au terme d'un scrutin plus que
mouvementée est ce que la tournure de
cette élection vous a surpris
bonjour non j'ai pas trop surpris parce
que c'est les règles la constitution
italienne qui prévoit 7 système
d'élection du président de la république
de façon indirecte donc avait à travers
le parlement mais j'étais un peu surpris
de l'incapacité les parties des grands
partis des droites et des gauches en
particulier la ligue de mater sa mini et
le parti démocrate de haricots l'état de
ne pas réussir effectivement à trouver
un candidat
rassembleur parce que c'est un peu ça
qui impose la constitution italienne
c'est à dire avoir une large majorité
pour pouvoir revivre le chef de l'état
qui en sanglots de l'unité du pays
et
je vais aussi
j'étais de surprise ne fait qu' on était
presque réussi à élire une femme à la
tête du pays avec événements qui étaient
elles avaient ou pouvaient dire avancer
des noms de personnalités plutôt plutôt
valable plutôt
apprécié par les italiens aussi
notamment la présidente du sénat mais on
n'a pas réussi on a obtenu beaucoup de
votes mais pas assez pour pouvoir la
lire tout cas toute cette situation
montre une défaite de la politique parce
que très concrètement comme l'a bien dit
votre reportage la fin il y avait une
crainte de la part de parlementaires
d'aller aux urnes dalé d'avoir une crise
d des gouvernements et donc de perdre
leur fauteuil est au parlement et je
vous donne tout simplement un petit
détail que
pour la loi italienne si on reste pas en
poste en tant que parlementaire pour un
4 ans et 6 mois grosso modo on peut pas
toucher la retraite de parlementaire
donc je pense que la prochaine crise
politique italienne arrivera le 22 23
septembre 2023 2022 parce que c'est
exactement la fin de ces quatre mois
quatre ans et six mois donc je vais
faire une pause alors bonjour sérgio
matar est là elle a été réélu alors que
lui il avait exprimé à plusieurs
reprises sa volonté de ne pas briguer
justement à second mandat
comment expliquer finalement cette
incapacité du pouvoir politique italien
a trouvé une alternative à au président
matar est là bas
encore une fois
matar est là et elle eu ce qui pouvait
éviter une à une crise politique dans
l'immédiat donc des élections anticipées
dans l'immédiat et donc ils ont les
parlementaires surtout ceux qui sont
justement à leur premier mandat et donc
il est il ils auront perdu ce statut et
ses privilèges ils ont troqué sept mois
de leur carrière avec sept ans de
mandat d'un nouveau président après je
ne sais pas si monsieur matériel acquis
quand même à 80 ans
continuera terminera son mandat comme ce
fut le cas pour son prédécesseur
giorgio napolitano qui était
effectivement réélu mais qui a
démissionné après deux ans à peu près
deuxième mandat et et mario draghi un
mot sur lui quand même l'ancien
président de la banque centrale
européenne qui était favori et ses
chansons diminuer au fil des scrutins
comment l'expliquer
parce que parce que beaucoup de
parlementaires ont eu peur aussi de
devoir une arrivée une crise
induite par le circuit européen dans les
choses que et mario draghi est très
apprécié dans l'est par les
gouvernements européens
surtout disons les gouvernements
mainstream comme solides et emmanuel
macron celui allemand donc si à voir
mario draghi as roma permet permet à
d'autres pays aussi d'être d'être
tranquille sur le fond dessus de
l'europe
mais c'est une réussite et mario draghi
paye le fait de gouverne depuis à allant
désormais est gouvernée fait perdre et
du consensus et en plus gouverné pendant
une pandémie c'est encore plus compliqué
et donc je pense qu'il est là qu'il qui
les moins appréciées par rouleau en
l'envoyant au queens à l'est on aurait
pu avoir à quelqu'un qui n'était plus en
phase avec l'époque manière parce que
malgré tout le peuple italien apprécie
aussi matériel a même si en ce qui
concerne les commis de l'huile est
toujours été un
supporter du vaccin et donc il a suscité
l'ire suscité des critiques de la part
de nos vaccins en italie ou en tout cas
des citoyens qui s est posé des
questions sur les routes qui veut des
doutes sur les vaccins et cette
réduction qu'est ce qu'elle dit en vue
des législatives à venir rapidement
que les partis politiques
vont avoir du mal à
obtenir la confiance des citoyens je
pense en tout cas que matteo salvini est
très proche de la fin de sa carrière
politique à droite parce que il voulait
être un peu le faiseur des rois il n'a
pas réussi à imposer sa ligne et dans
les sondages on voit que giorgia meloni
donc les l'un peu plus à droite de la
coalition de droite et
apprécie beaucoup plus appréciée qu'elle
lui parce que finalement
matin à venice subi un peu le la soeur
de marine le pen en france qui a eu d un
terme au mans par exemple sur l'euro sur
le maintien de la france en europe
salvini a fait un peu le même le même
jeu donc maintenant il les paye adroit
gauche rapidement je pense que là aussi
le parti de erik cole et à aura du mal à
obtenir d un bord d un bon nombre de
suffrages parce que il a trahi un petit
peu aussi des aspects tactiques d'une
partie de leur électorat c'est à dire un
mot d'abord l'élection d'une femme à la
tête de la république merci beaucoup
météo at il averti je rappelle que vous
êtes journaliste sheffield media.com et
spécialiste de l'italie